hey cousin let's make this easy and so
Yummy Teriyaki Simon Bowl in a pot going
on a low flame I add a fourth cup of soy
sauce water and sugar a teaspoon of
Ginger two grated garlic cloves a
tablespoon of sesame oil and some sesame
seeds combine a teaspoon of cornstarch
with two teaspoons of water give it a
good mix add it in and let this come
together in a low flame for five minutes
until it's thick like this then turn off
the flame I have two salmon fillets that
I Cube up I add a little garlic powder a
little black pepper a little paprika a
little sesame oil combined and I'm gonna
air fry the salmon at 400 degrees for 10
minutes no need to flip in the meantime
I make a quick spicy mayo equal parts
Mayo sriracha and a little teriyaki
sauce combined and that's delicious then
I coat the salmon in our teriyaki sauce
I build my bowl with white rice and
broccoli a little spicy mayo sesame
seeds scallion and enjoy cousin